I wonder, do you guys want to talk about attack on Titan?
Because Twitter's funny right now, Twitter is funny.
I mean, what is there to talk about? Like, I didn't realize.
How much for the clown Fiesta Twitter is about attack on Titan. How,
how is, how have people turned this into a thing to like dislike?
I don't understand.
I don't,
like I knew there was something wrong when I woke up in the morning and went on
to Twitter. Hashtag thank you. Mapa was training. I was like,
what the are these clowns doing now? It's like, every time,
every time I'm talking to Tyson air,
or you go on Twitter and something about attack on Titan is trending. Yeah.
So the time of recording is episode six schema.
Yeah. Yeah. And basically the most recent thing that happened was, uh,
what was it? People, people on Twitter were just attacking the staff members.
They were what's wrong. Like I think,
I think what I've read was some people were just harassing the director for one
of the music choices that was, that was made, um, in one of the big scenes.
And it got so bad that he had to deactivate his Twitter. He did. Yeah.
And a bunch of animators as well.
I'm literally watching this thing. Like, this is amazing.
Why are people getting angry? Like, is there like, what was wrong with the song?
Like who the knows? It's like,
I'm losing words because it's so so and dumb that you do
that you don't deserve anime. I'm just saying right now, like you just,
you just don't deserve it. Ain't a real animal, not a real anime fan.
If you turn off.
My mind, is that like, at the end of the day, a lot of these people, right?
We're just, we're just anime fans. Why on earth?
Do you think you have the right to that? Just go to like the director level.
I hate.
I will Udacity it a bit. Like you try and make an enemy. I see how you,
if you can make a good light, you know, what I want to do is like,
I just want to like kind of,
cause I think one of the things I saw yesterday was people were complaining
about, uh, one of the Titans being like really bad CGI.
And watching this thing. Right. And the CGI is honestly like barely noticeable.
It's really like, not even remotely.
Yeah.
I just want to like go off to all those people complaining about the CGI and
like link them to any scene from like bozo of 2016. Yeah. This one.
Well, whoever will take the clip. Right. And then run it through Sony Vegas,
call it 4k. And re-upload it. And be like, this is a 4k fight scene guys.
Like it's.
It's absolutely absurd.
[Inaudible] the descriptions like I fixed this fight. Dumbest thing.
Don't do that.
I, I, yeah. I mean, I was,
cause I tweeted out saying St like it nice and tight and be ready to be carrying
20, 21. Obviously not being a hundred percent serious about that. I'm not,
I'm not literally sitting there being like my 20,
21 would be ruined if attack on Titan. Wasn't Eric.
Like my God, the arguments that arose in there.
I, I made like, I made like an attack when Tyson tweet immediately muted it.
I was just like, I I've,
I've done this enough times before to know that saying anything about the attack
on Titan, whether positive or negative, you just set up,
you just set up a minefield.
It's like, I, you know, I tweeted it. I came back four hours later. And then,
you know, as I'm, you know, cause you refresh your Twitter,
you see the most recent reply.
And it was something about like Japanese whaling laws that they were arguing
about. And then I clicked on it.
[Inaudible].
I click on this thing and it goes up like 50 replies back and forth.
These two people going at it,
because one of them said that like [inaudible] season two was going to be
better. And they somehow devolved into like an attack on Japan. And I was like,
what the is past people have like anything else? I just,
I just don't understand how people can be angry about like a great
thing. Like even if they're CGI in it, that is barely noticeable.
What's wrong. It's getting adapted and it looks good. We're getting bored.
I don't understand why people are being so pathetic.
I feel like this is coming from the perspective of a lot of,
let's say more like entitled margaritas, right?
Cause you can be disappointed in some ways of anatomy adaptation, because there,
there,
there are some times when you read a manga and you have an imagination about how
this Mongo is going to play out,
if it was animated and with something like attack on Titan where the bar by
studio wits was set so high, right.
That you go to mapper,
which I still think mapper is doing fantastic job. We've had bankers.
So we we've had fun making bangers. And what I will say is like,
it's like the tiniest of nitpicks, right.
Where I would say that it's gone from like a 10 hour,
10 adaptation to like a nine out of 10 adaptation. That,
that that's that's, that's the thing. Right? It's it's,
it's a very slight step down from where it it's not bad by any step.
It's just a very slight step down. It's like, like, well,
people are taking that as if it went from like a 10 to a one. Exactly. Right.
And the thing is, it's a nine out of 10 adaptation for 10 out of 10 material.
You're still getting a banger. I don't get it.
Seven deadly sins, season three. So I don't,
I really do not understand the problem here. And like, you know,
these are the people who were, uh,
getting this nitpicky on Twitter and those manga readers are the exact same kind
of people who are just like when their kid's born. If that kid up anything,
they're like, well, it's ruined, it's fine. I, you know,
my expectation should have. You know what I mean? It's real.
Just like this is unlike what was in the hall, basing it off their own.
If it, if the child out that like, well, it. Didn't stick.
By looking at the ultrasound. They're seeing the baby born. It's like, well,
that's not, that's not, that's not a good adaptation.
You're telling me it's not going to be six foot. Honestly.
Just put it exactly the same.